حسنًا أندرسون، كما تعلم، هذه هي
الليلة الثانية على التوالي للهجوم الكبير الذي شنته
روسيا على هذه المدينة الليلة، وكان
أكبر بكثير مما حدث عندما تحدثت أنا وأنت
قبل 24 ساعة، وكان مجرد عرض استثنائي
للقوة النارية، لا أستطيع المبالغة في تقدير
أنني حقًا  لم أر أه شيئًا
مثل هذا أبدًا أه لقد رأينا آثارًا
تحلق في السماء من تلك المدافع المضادة للطائرات
رأينا تتوهج في المسافة رأينا
تأثيرات في السماء تبدو وكأنها تسبب
انفجارات وتلك أه من
تلك الأشياء سواء كانت  رؤساء شاه
شو كان لديهم طائرات بدون طيار أه أو أي شيء آخر
يتم إطلاقه من السماء، نعتقد أن
روسيا نفذت ضربة باستخدام
طائرات كاميكازي بدون طيار إيرانية الصنع والتي
تسمى رؤوس شو بالإضافة إلى
صواريخ كروز من العيار، هذا ما
يمكننا رؤيته وبعد ذلك  ما كنا نسمعه
أندرسون هو هذا التنافر الجنوني لتلك
المدافع المضادة للطائرات التي تطلق النار في
السماء من هذه الانفجارات الهائلة التي
يُفترض أنها من الصواريخ التي
أحدثت تأثيرًا أو تم إطلاق النار عليها من
السماء، من الصعب جدًا معرفة أنني أريد
تشغيل مقطع من  ما رأيناه في وقت سابق
الليلة حتى لا يتمكن المشاهدون من رؤيته فحسب،
بل يسمعون حقًا ما شهدناه
[موسيقى]
أجنبية،
تلك اللقطات المذهلة التي التقطها
المصور الصحفي سكوت ماكويني، كما تعلمون
عندما تحدثنا قبل 24 ساعة، كان بإمكاني
إخبارك بعدد الانفجارات التي سمعتها
يمكنني أن أحسب، كم عدد
التأثيرات التي سقطت الليلة، لقد فقدنا
العد بسرعة كبيرة، لقد كان يحدث
بسرعة كبيرة، وكان الكثير يحدث على
مدار ساعة تقريبًا، وأود أن أقول
إنه قد انتهى، أيضًا، لمدة ساعة تقريبًا.  لقد
كان هادئًا، نحن نبقي أعيننا على
السماء لأن الأشياء يمكن أن تتغير حقًا
في أي لحظة، وقد تنطلق هذه الإنذارات
مرة أخرى، ويمكن أن تطير أجهزة التتبع هذه مرة
أخرى إلى السماء، لكن
يبدو أن أندرسون كان هذا بمثابة رد فعل مباشر
وانتقام مباشر لذلك  الضربة التي شنتها
أوكرانيا على جسر كيرتش الذي
يربط شبه جزيرة القرم الروسية بالبر
الرئيسي الروسي في وقت سابق من اليوم،
قال الكرملين إن هجوم الليلة الماضية
كان انتقامًا مباشرًا علينا أن
نفترض أن الليلة هي نفسها التي
حذرت فيها روسيا من أنها لا تزال
تستكشف خيارات لهجوم
يبدو أن الرد الليلة هو جزء من هذا
الرد، وما إذا كان سيستمر أم لا، يبقى أن
نرى أن هذا
الوضع متقلب للغاية أندرسون